I have a couple of friends they become
Widow they start to live life after the
six you have a couple of friends and so
what
I was here like uh I I don't know much
him have like how many friends do you
have you said they're in their 60s I
lived over seven different countries I
made friendship or whatever I go but so
like uh good friends I have like five
but acquaintances I have a plenty and uh
I'll talk to a lot of people five
friends over 60 that are just living
their life happy no I mean like in
general I see when people they move on
their lives I'm just asking like how
many single older women do you know that
are genuinely happy
none of them would be happier with a man
that they respect and admire none of
them would be happier in that
relationship with a man they respect and
admire